let's talk about what you get with a
President Joe Biden with this story from
the Daily Mail White House apologizes
for glaring National Security blunder
after publishing photos showing the
faces of US Special Forces as they met
Joe Biden in Israel holy crap they
posted on Instagram a photo of all the
dudes and their faces H uh people are
are are commenting that these dudes are
basically they had their death warrant
signed pretty much they're not going to
be able to operate now people are going
to be looking for them their faces
that's it their faces are out there the
moment it was posted and this is the
Biden Administration and we might go to
war with this come on yeah man what
about the guy and my memory is not
serving me and pulling a Joe Biden at
this moment what about the guy that took
a picture on the submarine you know what
I'm talking about that they said it was
a national security risk he took a
picture in the submarine what how is
that different than a national security
risk of exposing something like this
doxing somebody and then Joe Biden his
administration were responsible why are
they not being held accountable man well
they just made a mistake because they're
the social media influencers right it's
just a little Millennial aeni mistake
right I mean like the obvious answer is
because the White House doesn't take the
security of our troops seriously no
matter how many platitudes Joe Biden
presents in his 15minute speech unless
it's on purpose what happens if Special
Forces get
attacked oh he'll just you know what Joe
Biden will be doing he'll be watching
his watch as the caskets are before him
with the American flag draped over the
bodies that he's responsible for
andow Americans today a a horrific
terror attack took the lives of Special
Forces the United States will not stand
for this and so I am hereby authorizing
the Detachment of insert whatever yeah
it's going to be and the cycle continues
yeah yep it's GNA be one of these flash
points I'm just waiting for the day when
they use one of these things that we're
all talking about for like their cass's
belly like like Tim been talking about
yeah yeah well what are you guys going
to do when World War II starts I was
thinking about hanging out in the store
room with all our food buckets and
closing door turn the lights off yeah
probably play Starfield play Starfield
Age of Empires have you been playing
Starfield is that any good yeah a little
bit yeah yeah I like it I think it got
too much criticism yeah but I've been on
age Age of Empires kick that's a good
one is there a new one no like aoe3
classic one wow old school yeah true
yeah what about what about you Scott
what's your plans for World War I you
going have a World War III party my goal
is to stop it I mean no I'm serious
Scott's got elections I told you he's
Republican Jesus my goal is to stop it I
I want people really understand how
consequential the next couple weeks are
leading into these
elections if we win these elections in
New Jersey Pennsylvania Virginia
Mississippi then our ourselves our
allies will be emboldened but if we lose
the Democrats will be emboldened the
military industrial complex will be
emboldened the establishment will be
embolden everything that we're seeing
right now is only going to be Amplified
so I mean really guys November 7th
Tuesday November 7th come out and vote
and think about it like even in Virginia
having Governor Glenn yunan empowered
having a trifecta state government and
and think about who lives in Virginia
you want to talk about contractors you
want to talk about the military you want
to talk about everybody that works at
the Pentagon those are all the people
living in Northern Virginia mhm yeah how
did you get into this like what was the
moment where you were like I have to be
the one to act because I'm so curious I
think there are a lot of people who say
this is an ISS but they don't take that
initiative I want to thank President
Obama no I'm serious he never gets
enough recognition on this show I feel
like I never know what's going to come
out of his mouth I'm serious no the
night that he was reelected uh I was so
mad I actually created my Twitter
account that night in November of 2012
People don't know that if you go look at
my profile right now at Scott Pressler
it says created November 2012 so fact
check me but I was just angry I realized
that look in action means you are the
problem and not the solution and I
wanted to be the change I wanted to see
I know as tired as that sounds but I'm
serious I just want people to give a
darn and to do something and most
importantly to take positive action it's
not negative it's not pejorative it's
not just shouting at the sky at clouds
on social media but doing something to
make a positive actual change you know
what I want to do I want to get a nice
recliner maybe those ones that have the
auta Mass I want to lay back I want to
order pizza and wings and I want to play
video games hang out with my friends the
only problem is we're not able to do
that when the world is falling apart
yeah and then while I'm trying to mind
my own business in my comfortable chair
I'm looking around be like no one is
doing anything about this yeah and then
someone's like well why don't you and
I'm like all right fine fine I guess so
I I'm I'm I'm only half joking I mean
the issue is I think there's there's
many things that we find enjoyment in
hobbies and and and things like that but
we are all driven to try and solve
whatever these problems are and and and
seek out the issues and do the work do
the work trust me I don't want this to
be my life I would love right now
instead of being here with all due
respect I love being here but I'd like
to be in a hat tub with an ice cold
Coffey watching a horror movie with a
lumberjack like
honestly we're in West Virginia so make
part of that have
it that would be my dream but you know
we're called for a time like this
honestly this work that we're doing
right here we're influencing lives we're
bringing this important news to people
that hopefully we can come together as a
family and we can solve those problems
thanks Obama I hope you get your hot tub
in your Lumberjack you deserve it Scott
do I was at a I was going to I was
getting food at a diner the other day
and walked past a liquor store that has
two two has a front entrance and a back
entrance cuz there's there's like the
commercial Street and The Shopping
Center Street but on one side where the
the the the uh the main road is there's
a big sign of the door saying this door
has been closed due to an increase in
shoplifting wow and I'm just like man
thanks Joe Biden you know like around
these parts yeah well this was more this
was Maryland you go to West Virginia I
don't recommend shoplifting because you
might get really hurt if you're like
taking stuff so you know don't don't
mess around with West Virginia that's
awesome Maryland though you know
Maryland is this really crazy you've got
as soon as you cross the River from
Virginia or West Virginia into Maryland
literally like right on the other side
of the river there are stories of like
roving bands of criminals who just beat
the crap out of people and steal their
stuff I'm not kidding you go to West
Virginia nothing I I wonder why I wonder
what it could be like separated by I
mean I'm sorry for being ignorant here
the carry law is that different in West
Virginia vers Maryland you will get
arrested you will go to jail you can't
carry it do you need a permit you need
good luck getting one
yeah good good luck wow in West Virginia
I believe the presumption is if you're
armed I I I so I think you need an ID I
think you need to be a state resident
I'm not sure actually no I don't think
that's true no you to be State res yeah
yeah yeah yeah if if you just like
you're from anywhere and you go to West
Virginia and you you have a gun
concealed or open it's constitutional
carry right not a crime there was a a
State Trooper who was watching arrest
someone once and he was like the guy
being arrested was like Hey that guy has
a gun and the trooper was like I know
it's West Virginia
yeah I know yeah you're in West Virginia
dude but you cross the you cross the
river right into Maryland and nobody has
any guns and it's because Baltimore
rules Western Maryland and that's why
Western Maryland West Maryland's like we
want to jump ship and join West Virginia
they tried yeah they wrote letters being
like we would like to secede from West
from Maryland and join West Virginia and
uh it's really funny because um what
wasn't there like a big lawsuit Virginia
trying to seize the panhandle from West
Virginia back in the day I don't know
like the Cumberland area yeah like
something happened where um first there
was a lawsuit over whether or not West
Virginia could remain a state after the
end of the Civil War but then there was
a question about the Panhandle counties
that were part of Virginia and they
wanted to be West Virginia and they were
like no and then it end up happening but
now even Maryland wants to join West
Virginia yeah well when when Western
Maryland wrote to uh the to Charleston
the capital of West Virginia West
Virginia and said can we please join
they were like for sure for sure ask
Baltimore now that's totally dead in the
water uh there's a couple counties that
border especially Eastern Panhandle uh
that have Clauses from way back in the
day you know back to the Civil War uh
that say you know should we stop liking
being part of Virginia we get to secede
and join West Virginia they just have to
act on it well but that's Virginia
though and so these are like it's not
Maryland Maryland is much stricter but I
don't I I I genuinely don't get this if
we are a a country that is founded upon
the consent of the Govern and the County
votes to join a different state the only
question is a question for Congress of
recogn not a question for Maryland and I
honestly think you can argue that
Congress doesn't recognize it but the
state laws should be immediately assumed
by West Virginia yeah true yeah I mean
if you even go towards Cumberland it's
feels like West Virginia because it
basically is West Virginia doesn't feel
like Maryland at all's cool though yeah
spot went to a coin shop there once
that's where I bought the coin that was
uh the same currency that was used by St
Casper to uh uh travel to meet uh uh
baby Jesus that's cool yeah I gifted it
to Sheamus cuz I thought it was cool we
don't know that the coin itself was used
by St Casper but it's it's the same
currency that was minted around the same
time that was used by him so you know
there may have been like a 100 coins
minted he got them and then this one was
minted for some other reason or it could
be one yet who knows who knows is that
the impetus for Casper Cathy no we have
cast brew
coffee here I am thinking Casper Coffey
I like it that's our
ghost it is Halloween yeah we have we do
have a Halloween is type blend makes
much more have Mr Mr Bokus pumpkin spice
experience the rise with Roberto Jr you
have a pumpkin spice one we have a
yearround pumpkin SP B come on business
lady but I don't I don't feel like it
tastes it it does taste like pumpkin
spice but you know it's not the same cuz
when you actually order pumpkin spice
somewhere they put the spices in it yeah
so this is like a pumpkin spice flavored
coffee so it's like you get what you get
like I'm not I'm not here to lie to
people like when it comes to the coffee
that we sell I think the pumpkin spice
is good I would I wouldn't I wouldn't
choose that one if I'm going to have a
I'm going to choose appach a kns it is
just insanely it's the best coffee I've
ever had I can't even no no no question
easy for me to say I'm the one who
formulated it like we got the coffee
samples and we we tested out a bunch of
different blends and then we came up
with ours and I love it I want to try
some of this we have some do onl a mess
yeah we should do a taste a bunch X live
oh yeah and Roberto Jun is super good
too rest in peace yeah I want to get one
of those limited edition ones I need to
get one limited edition the re the Reise
Reise that's an entirely different blend
though yeah still so do you think people
are going to be affected forgive me if I
already asked this question tonight but
with International skirmishes kicking up
do you think people will go to the polls
or do you think it'll not be enough to
break through voter apathy because I
feel like that's a problem in every
election cycle for both parties there's
a certain number of people that just
don't bring themselves to vote no I
think this is definitely
reinvigorating I mean look elections
have consequences we're this unfold
right now because Joe Biden is President
and the world doesn't respect him our
enemies don't fear us anymore and in
part is it possible that more people
voted in that Louisiana election because
of this I mean Israel happened right
before right um Hamas attacking Israel
were people inspired to understand the
gravity of the situation I firmly
believe so but more importantly I hope
this helps wake people up do do American
Jews do Jews across the world understand
that President Obama President Biden and
Democrats fund Iran and therefore fund
Hamas and therefore fund the attacks
against Israel does the Jewish Community
Now understand that their votes have
been funding terrorism yeah it's very
powerful this is a totally separate
question sorry for the terrible tangent
but how do you respond to calls for same
day voting uh I know this is probably
something that doesn't fit into your oh
no no I could talk about this all day
long I'm here I'm here to win I'm here
to defeat Joe Biden and make him a
one-term president and so therefore you
know I I want to preface this by saying
I understand people's hesitancy I
understand the Nostalgia of wanting to
vote in person on Election Day to lack
in your vote but the one thing that kind
of haunts me is I think of Nevada and
Adam laxalt was running for Senate he
lost his election by 8,000 votes 8,000
,000 now I'm not saying that the reason
why he lost is because it snowed in Reno
Nevada wasow County a republican County
on Election Day but what I do know is
150,000 Nevada registered Republicans
stayed home and didn't vote in 2022 I
know that for a fact lost by 8,000
150,000 Republicans stayed home and it
gets worse because all of those eligible
voters in Nevada receive a ballot
whether or not they request one that
means that people were so demoralized
dejected into spear or maybe they heard
from people don't vote by meal so they
didn't and they didn't even walk 10 ft
to their mailbox to drop it in 150,000
Oregon Oregon we lost by 62,000 votes in
the gubernatorial election
126,000 registered Oregonian Republicans
did not vote and there only a vote by
male State we could have a republican
governor in Oregon on the Left Coast
with all those hippies over there my
people had we actually just filled in a
meal and ballot and voted and so my goal
is guys look to you at home especially
the listener that's watching right now
please if we want to actually win this
year in November and next year in 2024
we have to have a diverse approach to
voting and look at Pennsylvania we got
880,000 Amish I am calling for the Amish
who get married on Tuesdays in November
because they are baby making machines
and they are doubling their population
twice in last century I want to get meal
and ballot in the hands of every Amish
person in America and I want to put drop
boxes in every Amish Enclave thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net